うねじゃあはじめ者像です
メリークリスマスと今日12月の24か
クリスマスイブなんですけれども今がです
ね今年といえばもうこの人たちでしょう
みたいなユーチューバーさん
平成フラミンゴさんが初めてはそのように
遊びに行きます
確かねとし金同じ年ぐらいから結構として
近いんですけども2回ぐらいお会いした
ことがあるんですけどもみなさんご存知の
通り僕女のパ好きなんですけども女の子と
話せないとして人見知りというの待って山
兄弟フラミンゴさんとお会いしてもなく
うまいこと話せなくて全然距離が縮まって
なくて結構緊張した状態で平成ぐらみんぐ
さー基づく待ってるんですけどomar だ
し思いつきました超対面でも女の子を
落とす方法
なので衛生フラミンゴのニコさん林美さん
俺を好きにさせて帰らせようと思います
多くなかなかで天才的な方法だと思うん
ですけども私はその一つの今回2人とも
同時に落としたいと思いますこの袋します
の日でどういう方法かといいますと分かっ
ている
もちろん普通に堂々と言ったらこの肇社長
のトーク力と女の子との話せなさを考える
と無理だと思うのでパズル車場の中身が
ローランドになってれば落とせますを断言
しますローランドを百戦錬磨ってよもう
ポットとしては名を挙げ女の子とも話も
うまい例え目でも絶対たくさん話せると
思うので私今がですね遠隔操作ローランド
とつながってローランドの指示を聞き
ながら今日お話ししたいと思いますつまり
あの見た目は肇社長なんですけども中身は
ローランドです初対面の女の子とどういう
会話をすればいいのかちょっと学びでも
しっかりと合わない言葉を聞かせて始める
とかっこよすぎるって2人に思わせて
初めてその子好きになってそれには帰って
いただきたいと思いますでは行きましょう
goo
にはめの
何使ってますかメロ s 2-
ハンディー館ハンディーカムするねっ
第だ海だ
間だけど
ねえか本当に代表ないんですけどね
宜しくお願
fate ザクッサービス歌ネット
こんにちははじめしゃちょー等
生のみんな肉ですよですよろしくお願いし
まーす
amaran
n ame
エレンか
確保塗るほど応援したことになりません
聞こえるはいえー一度です
いつでしたっけ涙ですよ
すれ違うしました運命的なんな聞こえて
たらちょっと軽く咳払いだけでけど a
うん
はいはい
分裂うちらもしてるん
ん
ついてよ
設定ですよ貼り付けましたか0あって
ジャイの茶という
なんか
かっこつけちゃって買ってるだけだって
ねっいやです俺の部屋汚いかなーっ聞いて
みてそれからダメだってウェッデル俺の
せいきたないかな
いや嘘くさ綺麗ですよそんな大人になり
ますん
友達遊び来てきたないって言われたんだ
けどやはり友達グってきたないって折れ
ちゃったんですけどこれがきれい正規たら
組めるだけでしょうかエフェクトの変化俺
がきれい席って汚く見えるだけですかね
ん
そう言われてみれば東京は創刊しん本当に
石炭すぎてき見れるなんだけどね
これ
役満です
やめでとうございます
まあかをちょっと近くで見てですからこれ
実物の方が可愛いですよね
普通の火をつけてみてもいいですかえっ今
言われ実物ロングかわいいですよねぇー
ma やけどめっちゃが入った蛇行して
めっちゃ綺麗なこうしてますかいいねぇ
はいごめんなさいメディックした僕の顔の
話をしてましたあったようじゃなメニュー
ずっと僕の顔の話をしてましたーーー
世界だから殴るんですが頑張らなくだけは
ありがとうございます ad ね今日全部
そうなんですかってくれてますですよます
ちなみに好きな男性のタイプとかいないん
ですかいい
津波に好きな男性のタイプと語ります
ています
山崎賢人さんですけど
今は顔はなるほどなるほど何気に聞いて
内面で何言われても青いまとかってもらっ
てね続けてって言って産駒が聞き出して
ない女
題名年件
2 sc ん
どうぞほかほか2年間に深いと思う総連
ぽいどうぞ
ここにはなんか無いから一般に私だけです
ね当てはまってるんだ続けてちょっと3つ
ぐらい聞いてあって放ってるの袁家て
もらっていいですか結構入ってもいいんだ
けどチャートので1あー
おれだで国立大学出身なんですねえろー
先ほどためている道後とか
は俺だねっ
こんなにお金使ってないんですよえっ
ぞそんな風てる6シャルっていうん
すぎていますちょっと飛ばしてみた
カレッツァの普通にずっと多く続けてみて
キー局
[音楽]
ブーブー言って a
お正月とか宇津木ても話せなくてええ
可愛い可愛い子に可愛いって言われた
嬉しいわいやー可愛い子に可愛いって言わ
れると嬉しいわええええええ料理に料理
褒められちゃいました
ですって言ってよりに料理込められた
気持ちだうわぁ
広部リーっていうか結構いうかそう食堂お
年だと思う
どうでしたか
夢みたい全部が夢だったんだよ
そんな現実味がありました
そうですよね現実味がないというそうです
本当にガーッとか当たったらん
確かに夢って
寝ながら見るもんじゃなくておきながら
見るもんですよね夢いっで
寝ながら見るもんじゃなくて大きいながら
見るもんですよね
何正伸的な
それね
ちょっと格好でございましたねかっこ
つけるっていうか格好ががついてくること
が多いんだけどね
こうつけるというより格好がついてき
ちゃうみたいな感じなんですよねああ
チェーンじゃなくなりについてきちゃう
ついてですよねから載せ方でと year
ず最初来年度甲府南空会来年チャレンジし
てみたいこと聞いてみて来年の抱負と書き
ませんが来年チャレンジしてみたかったと
か回復聞いてくれ
来年はチャンネル登録者数を300万人
おりません余裕でいきますよいやいや
おっかないですよねノートパソコン
すんグッズは
年第二回
2022年の頭ですか
そうですね
本番に入って次の目標なんですけど甘い
言葉いい
言い過ぎてそろそろ虫はなりそうになって
きてこれはない言葉言いすぎて
フォズ虫歯になってきそうで
靴型もあ全部セラミック上下なって反応
なった全部セラミックにしようかなと思っ
ててええ
それが来年の目標ですね
もうかよ俺意外と甘い言葉と結構入っ
ちゃっタイプなんだよね意外俺甘い言葉と
か結構イッツ与えてるんで
意外ですかいって
考えてないんですけどなんか誰かにそうさ
れているがヒーローじゃなきゃいけないん
ですけども選ばれたっ
ブーブちゃんと話し始めた
てみたいことがあればぜひええ
ええええええそして答えて俺も知りたい何
だろうめっちゃヒルドイドを塗ってます
シールド
磯津いいと加入人がやってたんですよ鋭い
カニっニキビと長谷川が入ってねそれを
塗りたくってゆっくりたで寝てます
みんな
3つにですよ
けどやっぱぴよって大事ですよいや実は
美容って大事ですよね
綺麗でいるってなんかばなーみたいな
なんか綺麗でいるっていう
まだみたいなもんですよね悪いだろうです
ね設定入っちゃってい
ブービー怒っちゃくしょっ
[音楽]
ブーバーンやってなかっあれっ画面越し
あってなくっ
よく黙っちゃって
こそ一の山ちゃんっ
雪
やって買うんですかああお土産ございます
ね
[音楽]
ブーブー言っ
か
あ印
[音楽]
ぬーんっ
イベントにくださいん
ちょっとあればいいんだ
市塚田九段な
俺バレンタインなんですよねぇー
[音楽]
ブーブ世界のカカオ畑絶命ちゃうからさ俺
た箒立っちゃったら世界いいのカカオ畑
絶滅しちゃうからなぁ
あった安倍さんが打つからってないからね
ちょっとなんか日目口になれたら嬉しいな
タメ口になれたらなんかちょっとそういう
感じでアプローチてみたい全然霊夢ゲーム
[音楽]
けどやめ良い心配です源さんこっちはん
ですいやダメダメって本当れっやるよーよ
次敬語使ったらなんか罰ゲーム決めない次
さ敬語使ったらちょっとバツゲーム決め
ないか
辻をそしてを分
一発ゲームずだなぁ
発芸てくださいめちゃめちゃ県とする愛の
言葉におお
[音楽]
0中田男に言われて嬉しいセリフとかは
なり取れないとか男に言われて嬉しい
セルフとかってあるえっぽいでえっ
おいっ
おいでー
ねぇ
と君です
ねにも作ったんかい
あ
3回目でしょ単回ばいいんでしょえっ
3回言ったらいいんでしょおっ極刑ちゃ
そうしようー優しいべっを合わせてくれて
ありがとう
言われて
夢 c するか意外たり指針に離乳はおい
ていただければ
ポリーで行って来たっ
ああ
を開いていたまいたい
fixed rate な感じんです
けれどねぇふーんじゃあちょっと経って背
を向けてそっか振り返って会いたいって
言ってみて
ああ
me
だいたいえっ
それ違ったかな今のはう
ブーブー意味しがリアの高好きかな
yeahじゃあ内田は帰り際に帰りにはに
寂しくなったら電話するねって言われてた
水降ったらと言いますよねって言われて
めりっにその直後に目の前でいるのにその
直後に目の前にいるのにまた電話してくる
ことか超好きまた電話スってくれることが
チョコー
44つ分0
寂しかったですねって言っ
すべてマッサージん
[音楽]
すぐさま店っていうのもなく
てくるのがすごい好き
楽しいな今日は
ブーブー言ってえっ
[音楽]
にょてるゲームで愛してるって言ってたら
負けだからね愛してるゲームで愛してる
って言っててれたら負けだからなって言う
わけですよねあったら市場来ないかいや私
でいいんですよあっじゃあ21
[音楽]
ブーブー女2人ぐらいだったら同時に行け
そうだからさああっ1回1対1でやってみ
ていいっ2対1で打っ
なつさんで同時に愛してるって俺ちょっぴ
行ってみてどれ絶対取れない気するわ
真ん中で折れて同時に打ってもらって
2人同時に入ってもらっていいオレそれで
もねと照れない子が住んだよに始めここ
普通に楽しんでっていうかピッター
ハーレーも楽しいでしょ
愛してる
ブーバー
しあっ愛してるで愛してるね愛してる嫁
あー
逆に誰だかねえ
オペラバージョンそれは2人がってこう
あー肩組んでお前を愛してるぜって言って
みて
いやー
おまえを愛してるぜ
さてたんだったのかクリスマスデートで
行きたい所がない目指すでデートスポット
とかできたいますとかないっ
んがっ le 若干焦り族カーン
イルミネーション大
鏡の前に立ってちょっと一緒に鏡の前に
立たないって言っていきたいでしょうか
えっ
ずれてあげるよいまうまぁ今
[音楽]
米ちょっとエリミネーションは今日は
ちょっとズレていますよ
ねいう全然よ
続ねスイートコーン
水族館
雫切るかにちょっと
9切る可能性族館水族館でたねーよ通知は
いけるけどねってゆうま水族館ネタ d は
ギターヘイター始めそれ言わなくていい奴
だったわ俺の心の声だったからさ
ごめんねうんネタじゃないよ
イルミネーションを目指さない
目指さないんだっ
なんかじゃすべく今やねそうねこうやって
よねおねいちゃーあっあっゴメンで自分
かっこいいからですか違うんだよ俺所どこ
行ってってそれは言わなくてや出せば
ダイナ戻っ
蜘蛛女だあああ
ねえねえ
ぬん
web さん
5はですね算数好きずいると思うんです
けど操作されていました
20ずっと色
スプーンいいせませんか
bouvet ますそれは今日
二人のことを好きにさせろ
[音楽]
サロンっ
えっ
ええっ
げっは
バッハ
[拍手]
ee いい
さあ悪い言い方さがってください
そうなんですよ実は
今日
午前中にがあっててレバー2人に合うから
私を
落としたいんだよねー
みたいな話をそれ本当に全然年間
変な感じだっけ汚れを持ったはなくまた
地面がさその女の子を脅したいって言った
じゃんをそんな落としている幹部がまず
いけねーなーと思ったは感覚がまず
そもそもうそーそーやっぱ
落ちるっていうか俺ウイルはお前が上がっ
ていくよしたんですもうああ
あー今回の研究でわかったのはロー何度が
言うからこそ
うさがあるっていうのはやっぱりなぜいう
かじゃなくて誰が言うかにもなくて俺が
言うと
[音楽]
ウォーカー
し